Chantal Hébert Michel David Véronique
prince bonsoir bonsoir je vous fais
écouter rapidement quelques extraits des
chefs de parties du Québec sur place à
Laval on écoute on revient
ben écoutez
il y a rien de plus dur que de
perdre un enfant ou de douter pendant un
certain temps là dans certains cas ça a
pris une heure avant de savoir est-ce
que c'est mon enfant qui est touché ou
non puis
on en parlait en déjeunant Isabelle et
moi puis on se disait on a deux enfants
imaginons nous demain matin
sera arrivé à notre enfant comment on
fait pour continuer à vivre si un
message que je veux lancer c'est
accepter l'aide psychologique
accepter d'aller parler parce que penser
aux enfants
même les enfants qui sont corrects qui
ont vu ça les employés qui ont vu ça
probablement c'est des images qui vont
garder dans leur tête toute leur vie
c'est important de démontrer notre
solidarité
de prier pour aller victimes et d'être
là pour les proches les parents des
victimes
des jeunes qui sont blessés et il y a
les blessures physiques mais également
les blessures psychologiques et on
accorde évidemment on est là dans plein
support pour tout ce qui peut être fait
il y a pas de place à la politique dans
ces occasions là le Québec parle d'une
seule voix on est derrière le
gouvernement
on se demande comme élu qu'est ce qu'on
peut faire devant une telle tragédie
d'abord on est là pour montrer le
soutien témoigner la solidarité et dire
à ces gens-là il y a toute la communauté
que quelque soit la suite des choses on
va être là pour les soutenir il y aura
des questions qu'on devra se poser comme
société dans les prochains jours dans
les prochaines semaines pour essayer de
commencer à comprendre ce qui s'est
passé je pense qu'on a reconnu un rôle
dans ces questionnements-là mais
aujourd'hui c'est une journée de deuil
une journée de soutien
moi-même ce matin c'est moi qui l'ai
fait au CPE mes enfants de 4 et 2 ans
faut partager cette douleur là soutenir
tous ceux qui ont vécu ce drame là donc
l'idée c'est de s'unir on est limité
devant des situations comme celle-là
mais si au moins il y a de l'amour puis
de l'entraide
c'est le mieux qu'on peut se faire
alors on est limité et puis monsieur le
goût le disait aussi on est on est sans
voix etc on est sans mot mais leur
présence de la classe politique montre
que ils sont toutes et tous touchées
Chantal
et c'est un rendez-vous certainement
difficile mais c'est incontournable dans
ce genre de circonstances-là mais c'est
là aussi qu'on mesure quand on est en
politique qu'on soit Premier ministre ou
chef l'opposition les limites du pouvoir
ici on n'est pas devant une situation
que quelqu'un aurait pu aurait dû
prévoir etc mais on est devant une
tragédie et en politique quand on se
demande toujours qu'est-ce qu'on
pourrait faire ou qu'est-ce qu'on aurait
dû faire ou est-ce qu'on va c'est il y a
rien d'autre à faire que ce qu'on avait
aujourd'hui Michel ouais et puis écoutez
ces gens là nous représentent je pense
que monsieur Legault et tous les tous
les chefs de parties on dit aux familles
des victimes ce qu'on aurait aimé leur
dire et qu'on pourra pas faire
mais il faut le temps et je pense que le
ton était bon il faut éviter toute
apparence de récupération le fait que
tout le monde soit là à l'invitation du
Premier ministre d'ailleurs fait que il
y avait aucune partie là-dedans ils
peuvent pas être suspects d'aucune façon
d'avoir voulu de serrer davantage la
situation et le ton était bon sur
monsieur Legault de façon il est pas
très bon dans la grande éloquence ce qui
le dit c'est exactement ce qu'il fallait
dire qu'on aurait probablement dit si on
avait été à sa place et il peut pas
faire grand chose mais le simple le
simple fait d'avoir quelqu'un qui
manifeste l'empathie dans ces
circonstances-là c'est déjà ça
et Véronique c'est le rôle de l'élu
effectivement de manifester cette
solidarité là puis de ressentir
l'émotion sur le terrain les élus
doivent être connectés sur le terrain
vivre ce que les gens sur place vivent
et après ça ça change leur perceptions
influence leur décision quand vient le
temps de mettre en place des programmes
puis des politiques si les élus font pas
ça même si on rien annoncé sur place ça
va se retrouver des gens dans des tours
d'ivoire finalement qui comprendront pas
réellement ce qui se passe sur le
terrain et la détresse des gens donc
c'était important qui se rendent sur
place quoi que on compulse lire sur les
réseaux sociaux là j'ai vu des gens
parler d'opportunistes politiques ça
c'est pas ça là c'est vraiment d'essayer
d'aller offrir un réconfort aux gens sur
place qui manifestement l'ont pris parce
qu'on voyait que les gens allaient vers
monsieur le groupe les chefs d'opposants
ils avaient envie de leur parler là on
trouve de tout sur les réseaux sociaux
le meilleur et le pire de toute façon
alors il faut que l'eau du fleuve ça
passe transfère en santé on revient dans
la joute politique
là les chroniqueurs dont
votre texte ce matin les chroniqueurs
sont plus fâchés que les premiers
ministres des provinces on a
l'impression ensuite à l'offre du
fédéral je veux entendre monsieur Ford
qui dit vous savez on est content qu'il
nous ait reçu on voudrait quelque chose
à plus long terme et monsieur Legault
c'est un extrait d'hier qui évidemment
est passé une aperçu hier mais qu'on va
écouter aujourd'hui on écoute et on
revient
notre club
ce Trudeau a dit hier c'est mon offre
c'est final bon je pense que on va
continuer à dire que ça a pas de bon
sens on va demander plus bon ce qui va
changer d'idée j'espère que le chant des
souvenir aux prochaines élections
écoutez
ce que je dis là c'est que c'est pas
acceptable donc les Québécois doivent en
tenir compte
mais ce qu'il n'a pas dit c'est qu'il
allait refuser il a pas dit qu'elle est
refusé chef David comment vous voyez la
position du Québec et des provinces
ouais ben vous disiez
que les politiciens d'une certaine façon
c'est vrai mais dans mon cas en tout cas
pas tellement fâché contre Monsieur
Trudeau je m'attendais pas à des
merveilles mais fâché ou en tout cas
déçu de la réponse de ceux qui reçoivent
des peanuts alors qu'il demandait la
lune et qui se disent bah écoute je
pense que ça on va s'arranger avec ça
alors là j'ai trouvé que la réaction
après ma base je me suis dit s'arranger
avec le gars des vues ça se peut pas
qu'il soit pas plus fort chez que ça
c'est qu'il y a un autre montant
d'argent qui s'en vient plus tard mais
là ça a pas l'air de vouloir venir alors
je trouve qu'on se flagelle et on tend
la joue autant d'autres joues d'une
façon qui après tout ce qu'ils ont dit
depuis 4 ans franchement c'était pas
c'est pas édifiant Chantal vous étiez là
le soir ou vous étiez à ce panel le soir
on a eu les montants d'ailleurs on peut
les revoir
46,2 pour toutes les provinces sur 10
ans d'argent neuf d'argent neuf mais
pour le Québec c'est à peu près un
milliards sur Oui sur 10 ans 46,2
jours plus tard et est-ce que c'est
parce que ce que demandait publiquement
les provinces c'était tellement une
somme qu'il savait qu'elle savait
qu'elle allait pour recevoir
ce que c'est une des explications de
leur réaction ils ont demandé deux
choses pas de conditions ce qu'ils ont
obtenu et la Lune ce que personne allait
leur décrocher et
ça pouvait avoir l'air d'une stratégie
de négociation on demande la lune pour
avoir quelques étoiles de plus mais à la
fin ça faisait que qu'il y avait pas de
il y a pas de chemin de contrat ils
peuvent pas revenir
penaud en disant moi finalement on
demandait la lune mais on aurait voulu
quand même plus
la rencontre des premiers ministres des
provinces qui devaient avoir lieu pour
qu'ils se conceptent demain et reportait
à lundi je suis pas convaincu qu'avoir
même avoir lieu parce que la vérité
c'est que le front commun des provinces
existe plus pour autant qui existait et
s'il existait on sait pas ce qui
arriverait ou ce qui pourrait dire c'est
pas une offre qui peuvent refuser
d'abord une augmentation de transfert en
santé ça surfuse pas ça se reçoit c'est
comme ça que ça fonctionne et là je sais
pas si vous avez vu monsieur Ford
aujourd'hui en Ontario qui recevait
Dominique Leblanc le ministre du Clos
qui avait l'air content
danser ensemble pour vrai mais dès le
premier jour il est content monsieur
un mot Véronique justement et même sur
le goût le premier soir la dégoûté on
peut pas refuser de l'argent qu'on nous
l'augmentation c'est pas ce qu'on
voulait mais on va le prendre autrement
dit donc il pourra pas le refuser et
puis comme dit c'est pas vraiment de
négociation c'est le Transfert canadien
c'est le fédéral qui décide c'est sûr
qu'on a l'impression que il y a pas
vraiment de levier finalement que le
rapport de force est pas très grave même
quand François Legault dit ben ça va
être aux gens de juger à la prochaine
élection fédérale même si la rumeur
court qui pourrait y avoir une élection
au printemps ici à Québec là je suis pas
sûr qu'à Ottawa cette rumeur là elle est
vraiment plausible parce que mes
collègues pensent qu'ils vont réellement
y avoir un élection au printemps donc ce
serait quand finalement que les gens
vont pouvoir juger en même temps il y a
deux choses là-dessus du côté de
monsieur Legault en fait de son cabinet
il perçoivent pas nécessairement comme
une offre totalement finale même si
c'est ce que dit Justin Trudeau donc
ils essaient de voir si la porte est pas
encore un peu en trouves verte avant de
la défoncer donc ça c'est une chose puis
aussi la stratégie des ententes
bilatérales parce que là chacune des
provinces va essayer d'aller chercher sa
part du gâteau chacun des provinces va
essayer de négocier de ce côté-là puis
quand on parle des enfants de
bilatérales c'est pas le front communs
c'est du chacun pour soi parce que ça
fait probablement partie la stratégie de
Justin Trudeau parce que lui c'est que
de ce côté-là il va pouvoir aller dire
mais regardez je respecte mes promesses
électorales parce que les provinces
acceptent d'investir que ce soit en
santé mentale en santé publique peu
importe puis d'un autre côté les
provinces pensent en tout cas j'ai
l'impression qu'au cabinet monsieur Lego
il pense que Justin Trudeau du côté des
attentes bilatérales a peut-être un peu
de marge de manœuvre pour en donner
davantage on imagine un peu plus mais
Michel David est-ce que fondament parce
que Monsieur le goût depuis le début dit
moi je suis avec Monsieur Ford on est
ensemble là-dedans on se tient Unis
est-ce que s'il avait déchiré sa chemise
s'il avait été très mauvaise humeur le
premier soir est-ce que ça côté plus
difficile vis-à-vis des Québécois qui
expènent après pour dire ben c'est un il
aurait dû reconnaître que c'est un échec
alors que Ford à côté dit ben moi je
suis plutôt content de tout ça là ouais
ben je pense qu'il y a compris monsieur
Lego depuis un bon moment quand monsieur
Ford dit quelques semaines
ou mois moi les conditions ça me dérange
pas là je pense monsieur Legault s'est
rendu compte qu'il y avait de l'eau dans
le gaz là et que le front commun en
réalité n'existait plus si tentait comme
disait Chantal qui l'est déjà existé
maintenant à partir de maintenant là
monsieur Legault il peut bien dire
monsieur Trudeau va payer le prix à
l'élection et tout ça quand ça va se
mettre à aller encore plus mal que ça va
déjà c'est difficile à imaginer mais ça
peut arriver dans les services de santé
pensez-vous que c'est Monsieur Trudeau
qui va être blâmé pas du tout aussi le
Québec les provinces qui administrent
leur système de santé alors quand il va
avoir une crise comme ma maison neuve
Rosemonde il y a deux semaines trois
semaines c'est c'est le monsieur Dubé
puis monsieur Legault qui qui vont aller
qui vont passer au battre si vous passez
l'expression alors même dans la comment
dire dans la réplique politique je pense
que monsieur Legault a pas grand levier
sans doute que monsieur Legault était
occupé par d'autres choses hier et on le
comprend mais il y a peut-être manqué où
il y a peut-être pas lu le transcript du
point de presse de Pierre Poirier qui
sont seuls cheval de rechange crédible
dans les intentions de vote si c'est pas
Justin Trudeau que les élections aient
lieu demain matin ou dans un an et demi
puis à poil libre qu'est-ce que dit hier
il y a dit je vais maintenir les
engagements que Justin Trudeau viennent
prendre il y a pas dit et je vais les
bonifier d'ailleurs les conservateurs en
fait un détour pour pas dire avant la
rencontre on appuie les demandes des
premiers ministres il a dit aussi il y
en a pas d'argent c'est la faute à
Justin Trudeau etc mais en clair c'est
beau de dire on verra aux élections mais
il va changer 4,25 sous pour un dollar
oui c'est important
de Michel et Véronique mais jamais
j'avais posé la question qui est venu
nous voir jamais engagé à donner
beaucoup plus
non
certainement pas et d'ailleurs ça aurait
pas été disons cohérent avec son
discours habituel qui dit toujours que
Monsieur Trudeau dépense trop alors là
il est super content parce que là il va
pas dire écoutez j'adore ça et lui si
les gens sont pas contents mais c'est à
cause de Monsieur Trudeau là c'est pas
moi qui est négocié cette entente là
alors lui il doit être très très heureux
aujourd'hui et là Véronique le défi pour
monsieur Legault dans les prochains mois
c'est d'améliorer ce système là et de
montrer au Québécois que même si il a
pas eu tout l'argent qu'il souhaitait le
système va s'améliorer quand même que
lui va investir il va continuer à
piloter tout ça François Legault a dit
on obtient quand même un milliard de
plus par année on fait quand même des
gains index
45%, le plan santé de Christian Dubé va
quand même pouvoir se réaliser à partir
du moment où il admet que le plan
Christian Dubé ne va pas être affecté
par les transferts de santé qui sont pas
aussi élevés qu'ils le respect c'est sûr
qu'à ce moment-là ça devient un argument
en faveur de Justin Trudeau ça c'est
clair donc je sais pas si cette
admission là stratégiquement au niveau
de la communication était la bonne chose
à dire cette semaine très bien très
intéressant merci Chantal Michel et
Véronique je souligne que Monsieur
Trudeau sera ce soir à la veillée à
l'église Sainte-Rose de Lima donc à
Laval merci beaucoup au revoir à très
bientôt